I think it's the only shot that the
Republican Party has is that it it
adopts the libertarian of many of the
libertarian principles the status quo is
not working doesn't work didn't work
it's not working in his work for the
presidential campaigns of Ted Kennedy
and Walter Mondale to promoting
democracy in Africa political consultant
Joe Trippi has changed politics in
fundamental ways in 2004 his pioneering
use of crowdfunding helped launch Howard
Dean to the forefront of Democratic
candidates reason TV spoke with trippy
at national school choice week in San
Francisco to discuss his surprising
predictions about the inevitable death
of political parties and the rise of
libertarians as an enduring force in
American politics hi I'm Todd crane in
with a reason TV we're here at national
school choice week in San Francisco and
I'm here with Joe Trippi good to be with
you
so what brings you here in general what
what is your what is your I've been
involved with the school choice week for
a few years now I think three or four
actually but I've always been a
proponent of more choice in schools I
mean I'm not there's some of some ideas
with education reform though I'm not for
but I think hey the status quo is not
working let's quit everybody's ideas on
the table everybody's including hey if
your support the current public school
system the way it is you know that let's
let's talk about it but I don't think
it's working I think families should
have choice I did you know when when I
was growing up we were right on the line
and one district was gangs and a bunch
of kids that weren't getting very good
education weren't going on
weren't even graduating from high school
the other on the other side of the line
the schools were better safer fewer
gangs
and most of the kids were doing well and
had a shot at college I was our house
was on the wrong side of the line and my
mother who raised five kids by herself
went down there fought like crazy and
got me somehow talked them convince them
that they should let me go to the good
schools and you know the whole thing
watching her do that just made me I mean
soon I'll talk at five years old six
years I'm not talking like I came to
this yesterday it's like what why is it
that that she had to fight to get me
into the school that was safe the reason
school choice week is because technology
is moving so fast that most government
bureaucracies can't keep up with it one
of them is is education just just
textbooks taking seven years to get an
economics technical textbook into a
classroom how is it the kids like me
can't can't decide what school they're
going to that so they're born or raised
in that district that's where they're
going that's been wrong for 50 years and
by the way if you want any proof of it
go into those neighborhoods today
because they're this they're still there
you've been sympathetic to the movement
for a long time know I've been for
school choice ins since the day I
entered kindergarten
we've got more choice at a 7-eleven than
we do in in how we educate our children
it's like crazy I'm always reminded that
scene in the Moscow and the Hudson when
Robin Williams cannot believe the amount
of it's either toothpaste or coffee that
to choose from having come from the
Soviet Union he literally becomes
overwhelmed by the whole whole
experience
he collapsed yeah yeah yeah and the
story in the in the aisle of the 7 yeah
coffee coffee coffee
you got bored 500 cable channels but one
size fit all school right something
fundamentally American about having
yeah yeah I'm wondering okay so given
that I wonder if we can pivot a little
bit more traditional up topic of
politics and sort of the inner workings
of it and I'm just wondering what you
make of the rise of libertarian politics
within the Republican Party is that a
lasting transformative shift that's
happening out or is this something that
may peter out within a few years I think
it's the only shot that the Republican
Party has is that it it adopts the
libertarian Oh many of the libertarian
principles and sort of that wing of the
party or that that impulse within the
party emerges as the leader of the
future for the party you know
demographically the it's going to be
very tough for the Republican Party as
it's currently constructed to win a
national election I don't see it
happening in the next in 2016 or 2020
and I think part of that is twofold
when you have a party that's that that
is so reliant on white voters and I'm
not you know that's just a fact
I mean you they're getting you know
Romney got nearly 60% of the white vote
and almost you know pretty much nothing
among everybody else here's a problem
when older white voters are dying and
the younger vote white voters are very
libertarian the younger generation is
probably the most libertarian and sort
of tolerant and it has more libertarian
values I'd say then any generation in
our in American history if the
Republican Party picks the Tea Party as
the the party of the future that's it's
over for the Republicans I mean then I
think the libertarians may have to and
and might very well succeed in creating
another party because I think there's
plenty of Democrats who are much more
fiscally who would love to see a party
that
were a political philosophy that is
fiscally sound fiscally responsible
socially libertarian or tolerant I mean
those that combined and so you've got
elements of that elements of dad and the
Democratic Party elements of it in the
Republican Party but the Republican
Party doesn't seem I mean because of the
Tea Party and other factors doesn't seem
like it's willing to go that way
although we'll be interesting is be
interesting to see how Rand Paul and
others do in the in the presidential
primaries of 2016 yeah I was gonna ask
you about Rand Paul specifically because
it does seem like in order to resolve
that tension between the establishment
Republicans and the libertarians and the
tea party as it were it's going to take
some kind of individual a leader that
people will gravitate to and I'm
wondering in your view is that gonna be
Rand Paul is gonna be someone else
is he the kind of person who can he's so
far the the likely embodiment of you
know if true could you know of who's
gonna raise the flag and try to take the
hill and I think has a real shot of
taking it you know there's gonna be a I
think a you know a fight of titans two
or three I mean I think what you know
whether its establishment Tea Party
libertarian but those three at least two
are going to emerge as the top two
contenders and then have a real huge
fight to the nomination I expect it's
going to go into a probably a floor
fight at the convention
much like Kennedy Carter in where the
Democratic ademma we had you know the
Liberals and I was with Kennedy you know
we had this knock-down drag-out fight
that starts the process of leading to
Bill Clinton being I mean it took a long
that that fight came to a head in 1980
but it took
a while and often what happens is when
you have these kind of big schisms in
huge fights for the nomination it's very
healthy for the party the party becomes
much stronger and finally finds its path
to the future and a much more successful
path to the future but that year is
usually pretty bad for the party I mean
you know we Reagan won the presidency
short term is bad but yeah yeah and
that's what I kind of might if you were
asking me what's going to happen in in
2016 I think what's going to happen is
the Republicans going to have a huge
fight if I were looking at that party
and you know we're trying to look at
what's the best path to the future I
think it's libertarian but then hey I'm
I'm a little Democrat so they're not
gonna take my advice but you know we'll
see what happens I was also gonna
mention that there's others seem to be
other sort of unclaimed issues by the
mainstream establishment that are on the
table things like the NSA or certainly
raising that as an issue or drug
legalization within the States
yeah no no look I think the the issues
that are emerging are really coming to
the fore for Libertarian candidate I
mean in a the both parties establishment
are not likely to take on the national
security apparatus in a meaningful
meaningful way I you know I don't see
Jeb Bush and Hillary Clinton having a
big fight over the NSA I mean it may
come up I'm not it's obviously gonna
come up and there are beliefs are gonna
want to change it here and there but I
don't think they're gonna have a big
fight of where I think a voice out there
of like Rand Paul raising that issue
there's a lot of room for that a lot of
room on on on drug you know legalization
of drugs and
and reforming how you know the how we
you know the different in prisons and
other things when and when you see
states all over the country starting to
move Washington and Colorado you know
moving to legalization of marijuana the
interesting thing is I'm not sure there
are enough votes in the Republican Party
for that you know are there enough votes
for somebody who speaks out for
legalization of marijuana for instance
it's just one
I don't think so is there enough votes
between libertarians in the Republican
Party independents and Democrats in the
in the Democratic Party when you know
it's very doubtful that establishment
candidate and the Democratic Party is
going to be for those things either so I
think there's plenty of room the
question I've got is whether it's wise
to keep trying to fight for the room
within the Republican Party or whether
it would be smart or given basically how
both how the country's upset with both
parties I mean this was pretty much
close despises both of them isn't now is
now not particularly contentious um
buddy to actually break away from one of
the two parties and try to create a
third a third way Libertarian Party I
think there's plenty of room for someone
like that and and that might be smarter
than trying to trying to run within
against the establishment of either one
both both parties are really really
really good at killing interactions
within taking on the party establishment
anything they set the rules the right
way to do that I mean it's all fat and I
mean I know because I've gone up against
the establishment in my party you know
more time so it's like banging your head
up against the wall and it happens the
Republicans are actually even better at
shutting down an insurgent or co-opting
yes exactly and and so that's that's one
sort of fissure that looms in the
horizon but another one is is technology
and you've talked about how
you don't see the Democrats and
Republican but Democrats and Republican
parties is having the kind of entrenched
duopoly that they have that they've
enjoyed for what 150 some odd years and
that technology can play will play
you're quite confident that will that it
will play a really disruptive force in
that in the future and I was wondering
if you could discuss that the Internet's
gonna wipe out both parties at some
point I mean or make them less able to
control everything I mean there's gonna
be a third we're gonna have any
independent president and in to put more
independence in the house and the in the
Senate look you the only reason you
needed the parties were the the the
platform policy platform think tanks
things like that the money the the
infrastructure of raising money and the
infrastructure of organize for the
organization that was a well both party
platforms are you kidding me
meet none of the nominees of ever I mean
in recent times have ever paid any
attention to their platform let's apply
crazy people right your platform and I'm
gonna go do say whatever I want to say
and run TV ads anyway so there's no no
one doing that I mean the platform
committee has nothing to do with it
money you know both Howard Dean and
Barack Obama and in Ron Faldo over large
degree showed they you know millions
hundreds of thousands millions of
Americans giving $10 $25 can out can
compete with the likes of a Romney or or
a Hillary Clinton money machine and and
you don't need the parties but the big
donor base in fact by the way if enough
people give you five and ten dollars
trust me the big money base suddenly
discovers you too so and they'll
discover the third the the
and independent if if the person starts
to take take over an organizationally
same thing the internet and technology
makes it possible I mean the individual
candidates can with attractive ideas can
get hundreds of thousands of people
millions to sign up and go work for them
on the street knocking on doors making
phone calls that way outflank the party
organizations and either in either party
in a given state or county or whatever
so those those three things are totally
gone you know but but Ross Perot in 92
when he ran the first time had there was
no internet I mean there was but there
were like few people on Ross Perot went
into the lead people forget this you
remember he was taken Olivo he had taken
the lead with the internet with what
we've got now with Facebook and Twitter
and in people's emails and people sent
in five or ten doubt you you know I'm
not I'm not saying he would have one I'm
just saying it would have been a
completely different game or had he been
racing the money was never an issue for
Pocoyo
I meant about people having that kind of
ownership where they're actually able to
communicate and sign up somebody's gonna
do it and somebody who can get people's
attention and and create a following
could could easily swamp the two parties
I'm curious to you know every few years
technology just moves over crazy fast
now that every few years there does seem
to be a transformative new technology
you know earlier was talked about in the
Dean campaign was crowd funding for
example and then I remember in an
interview I read of yours about four or
five years ago you were saying you know
with the YouTube age it's video now is
going to do things is there something on
the horizon now that has that kind of
transformation transformative power in
politics a new a new technology or
emerging technology well no I mean I
think big data is still get a which had
the biggest impact of 2012 I think that
was really what
what gave Obama a big advantage over
Romney they weren't even on the same
playing field I think at least today
that's gonna even be on it's big data on
steroids in 2016
you know Moore's law where we dumped
computer power double of every 18 months
to two years
the leaves are exponentially I mean like
off-the-charts massively disruptive and
big and that's not just gonna change how
a campaigns wage it's why government
can't keep up that laws can't keep up
everything now is and the reason
everything feels faster is because of
that the size of the leak the size of
the leaps now only get bigger and more
disruptive like all the disruption of
the last 30 years is now gonna be
sandwiched into the next two years
I mean life as we know it is really
radically gonna change a lot of old
ideas are gonna be revealed as obsolete
that that may be an opening also for
libertarian or some other force the base
orthodoxy of both parties is going to be
revealed I think is obsolete Bush spent
a lot of money Obama spent a lot of
money that Fed is quantitative easing
and did not like make everybody one or
like weird every government on the
planet is printing money faster than
that as fast as the press hold the
printing press hold print it and they
still can't inflate their way out of
this should you know this is the old way
because that's the old way and it's not
working and I think we've seen plenty of
places where they went
totally totally cut back tighten the
belt really hard and that's not working
well at all where's that happen huh oh
yeah that's a good point but I mean that
what I'm saying is I don't well I don't
I've not a I don't think that would be a
smart
a smart answer to the to try it and we
look Instagram 15 people start Instagram
launched Instagram Eastman Kodak 186,000
people who will never work in
photography again chemical engineers who
were ok it's 15 people 186 thousand
people those 15 people are gonna make
millions when the IPO and they got
bought by Facebook right right so and
the 186 thousand are doing what today so
what I'm saying is that is all gonna
speed up that the disruption is going to
yeah now I think both parties have
plenty of people in them that are
capable of thinking differently and
starting to put different ideas out
there but the establishments in both
parties won't are not going to let them
do that that's the that's the so that's
where I think there is a big opening
whether it's libertarian or not I mean I
think there's a big opening for someone
for someone in some things some new way
of thinking about it mostly because they
won't have an establishment to do it
like the Ross Perot or the Jesse
answerer those are like template yeah
more than this you know I'm also like
not you know you know naive and think
you know anybody can walk into that it's
gonna have to be somebody with some real
ideas and whose really thought about it
and I think that's where libertarianism
it's got some real possibilities because
there is a philosophy there that's got
its look I think there are plenty of
people in the Republican Party who are
attracted to libertarian principles I
don't think there's enough of them to
win the Republican nomination I could be
wrong and I'm be happy to to find out I
am I think there's plenty of people in
the Democratic Party you retract find
some ideas of the libertarians
attractive and we'd appeal to them not
enough to win the Democratic nomination
so what keeps happening is you have
these libertarian candidates who
to decide to run for the Party nominee
you know or the conventional way wait
you've conventional way and there aren't
enough votes in any one party for them
to do it there are I think enough votes
out there potentially to to run as just
a straight-up
libertarian here's my ideas and forget
about these two parties and let's do
this different
I'm not saying that'll win but I think
that's a better shot than then trying to
become the Republican nominee that's a
you know but I still think Rand Paul's
gonna try to become the Republican
nominee through by a convention yeah
right and then and so the two-part look
one thing the two parties need the best
thing either party's got going for them
the other party right I mean you know
come on it's so a Democrat you know the
best thing we got going for us is the
Republicans yeah but maybe maybe I'm
sure they're plenty Republicans you
think the same thing but maybe someone
like Rand Paul who is young tries the
conventional way a time or two it
doesn't work out as you bring yeah yeah
sure and then they start saying well you
know maybe this time to do it yeah 21st
century a true 21st century campaign
that bypasses the park yeah the partisan
politics soli possible yeah great cool
on that note thank you very much Joe
Trippi I appreciate talking no it's good
good to be with you and I hope I don't
get in too much trouble let me taste I'm
Todd craning for a reason TV I'm Joe
Trippi
you